good day and welcome i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia and i am
delighted to welcome you to this edition
of our
2021-2022 foundations of biomedical data
science seminar series this lecture
series is supported by uva's integrated
translational health institute of
virginia the uva brain institute the
college of arts and sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from
the national institutes of general
medical sciences this year's theme
is ethical challenges of artificial
intelligence and biomedicine where every
friday we enjoy presentations from
leading thinkers about the promise the
opportunities and the hurdles associated
with ai applications in the biomedical
sciences selected participants in our
biomedical data science innovation lab
program will leverage these
presentations as vital material for our
culminating in-person grant project
development workshop to be held here in
historic charlottesville virginia in
june today i am delighted to welcome our
speaker dr allison antis from washington
university in st louis
allison is an associate professor and an
organizational psychologist with a focus
on the ethical conduct of research
she is the assistant director of the
center for clinical and research ethics
where she co-directs a responsible
conduct uh community
of research scholars teaches courses um
and holds other activities
for
the folks at washington university she
also teaches course courses on ethics
and professionalism um in research as
well as in biostatistics she has a
specific interest in the role of
leadership management practices and work
place behavior in conducting high
quality responsible research and is
interested in the societal impact of
that research in particular she has
conducted her own research on the best
practices in ethics education and the
assessment of ethics courses she is a
co-investigator on the professional and
social issues in the so professional and
social issues lab which focuses on
research examining factors that foster
and hinder research integrity and
practical interventions aimed at
enhancing professionalism and ethical
decision making in research in
continuing our
2021-2022 biomedical data science
seminar series theme allison's lecture
today is entitled ethical interactions
in scientific teams as a foundation for
ethical ai allison's lecture will
explore the individual factors and the
interpersonal dynamics which influence
shape and which guide the ethical norms
and behavior of scientific teams and she
will make the case that ethical
interactions within teams is essential
for the ethical development and
deployment of ai innovations
her lecture will discuss challenges
which arise in multidisciplinary teams
and strategies for navigating those
challenges as always we are streaming
this lecture live and for recording via
youtube and if you are watching via
youtube thank you so much for joining us
also our specially selected
2021-2022 biomedical data science
innovation lab participants are
encouraged to submit any questions for
alison via the chat feature in their
zoom sessions i'll synthesize these
questions i'll ask them at the in the
last 10 minutes or so of allison's
lecture end with that alison welcome we
are so excited to hear from you today uh
we've really been looking forward to
your lecture thanks so much
hi and thank you for inviting me i'm
pleased to be here and i'm looking
forward to
sharing
my talk with you today and then getting
some good discussion going towards the
end
so just a great introduction thank you
so much for that
um this next slide here just shows you
a couple of
my papers looking at leadership and
management and research as you noted and
then i also do some work in the space of
um
public perceptions and research
participant and patient perceptions of
the use of ai and healthcare
and as you noted i'm at washington
university in saint louis on the medical
campus in the bioethics research center
which is our newer name
and i conduct empirical funded
empirically funded empirical research
funded by nsf and nih
in the center i also wanted to mention
two of the professional development and
training programs that i'm involved with
involved in one is called the
professionalism and integrity and
research program this is a coaching
program for researchers who um have
issues in their research laboratories
and their centers that they direct or
in their teams and so
today's presentation is going to pull
together my own experience as a
researcher leading a leading research
and being a research team my experience
studying behaviors in the research
environment especially leadership and
management and my experience coaching
researchers who have challenges that
come up so examples would be
issues with data integrity that
ultimately lead to retractions
issues with submissions that lead to
investigation by um
central funding um agencies so these
researchers are really looking to pick
themselves back up and get their careers
back on track and we always say that
they're really great researchers and
they missed you know some of the details
some of the important features and then
things escalate and become problematic
so i really like pulling together what
contributes to effective research teams
and then looking into these issues and
these challenges and thinking about how
all these things triangulate to these
same kind of stories about what
contributes to effective
ethical research and then this other
program i'm involved with is so new that
it doesn't even have a logo yet and the
name compass is mostly solidified but
we're still exploring and making sure
it's the way to go so this is a program
that's funded by nih
to help train and develop
junior faculty and postdocs and
leadership and management skills as
they're navigating the early stages of
their career
so this will be open nationally to all
researchers who meet that general
criteria biomedical investigators um and
and who are junior faculty or postdoc
and um
it'll provide training around leadership
and management skills and it'll also
allow the opportunity for mentoring both
in peer groups and from experienced
researchers who have already been there
and done that so just wanted to tell you
about those programs and make that point
that i'm pulling together my own
research my own experience and then my
experience training and developing
researchers
so what are we going to do in this talk
um i'm going to make the case that
ethical interactions within teams are
essential for the ethical
development and deployment of ai
intervention so i'm going to talk about
what it what i mean by ethical
interaction what does that mean what
does ethical interaction mean in teams
um
then i'm going to make the point that
individual and team behaviors and
dynamics drive scientific excellent and
ethical research and
and innovation
and i want to talk about what do these
behaviors and dynamics look like
and then finally i want to get practical
um i really like to do that where i take
my research and then i start looking at
how do we apply it
so i'm going to give you some practical
suggestions and some tips and some
guides some checklists and talk you
through that and hopefully these will be
of value to you in the future so um
i'm known in the center
and on campus as the relationship matter
person um which i'm willing to
accept that as the as my um
uh how i'm known and soon you'll see why
first i'd like to share some statements
with you for you to reflect on
when i have ideas i know that i can
share them and people will listen when i
have concerns about a project i feel
comfortable bringing them up
when others share their work i know they
value my input and feedback
i can count on team members to give me
constructive and valuable input and
feedback
when something goes wrong my team
members band together to figure it out
i feel like my contribution matters to
my team members
something bad happens in my life
it's okay to say that i'm struggling if
something positive happens in my life
it's okay for me to express excitement
i'm not worried what others think of me
i feel that i can be myself in this team
so just reflect on those statements for
a second
these are statements that a person in a
psychologically safe work environment
would make in this kind of environment
you feel and believe that your team
expects you to speak up
that's just how your team does things
you believe others will give you the
benefit of the doubt if you challenge
something take a risk or make a mistake
you're able to talk about problems and
concerns learn from failure and openly
share ideas no matter your status or
hierarchy in the um in the team you can
be yourself without fear of judgment
just to say a little bit more
about what is
a psychologically what is psychological
safety at work
it's a shared belief held by members of
the team that others in the team will
not embarrass reject or punish you for
speaking up
um
ccl is a major center for creative
leadership is a major leadership
development organization that's very
evidence-based and one of their chief
officers says people feel
comfortable being themselves they bring
their full self to work and feel okay
laying all of themselves on the line
so in this kind of environment people
feel they can voice un undeveloped
thoughts they're not fully formed yet
they can ask naive and seemingly random
questions they can brainstorm out loud
and they can give and receive
constructive feedback
many of you have enough experience in
the research environment that you're
starting to see wow those seem like
important features of um doing effective
science being able to have those things
happening
um
it is
important to know this doesn't mean that
everyone is
is super positive and nice all the time
like that doesn't mean there's never any
kind of conflict or um clashing or
tension that comes up it's just that you
can speak about it and you know that
you're gonna work it through and that
your team has your back and you have
their back
um
and there's emerging work and
conversation around not only the
importance of psychological safety for
fostering innovation
and effectiveness at work but also that
it's fundamentally um
about inclusion because in order to be
included and feel like you can learn and
grow and that you can speak up and ask
random questions
you have to have this kind of
environment so it's really
um
creating a kind of environment that
establishes all these features of what
we're really hoping to have in
scientific teams we're hoping to have
people who feel like they can be their
whole selves they can bring all of their
talents and skills they can speak up
they can ask good questions and as you
know this is even more essential in
multi-disciplinary teams because you're
all coming from different disciplines
you have different languages and so when
someone uses an acronym or jargon that
you don't understand you need to be like
hey what the heck is that i need you
know that comfortability to speak up and
um ask those random questions and to
bring up those what if questions
um
as you're going about your work
so that's what it feels like to be in
this kind of environment that's what
psychologically safety feels like and
that's what it is at the individual
level but what creates psychological
safety at work
the short answer is a positive team
climate so positive team climate is the
basis of psychological safety at work
and
a positive clean team climate
is characterized by interpersonal
interactions that have trust respect
openness transparency and honesty
information sharing exchange of
perspectives and support
and you can see that
yeah this is good for people this makes
people feel like they can be their full
selves it fosters well-being and
engagement and inclusion at work but
it's also essential to innovation the
responsible science
so these features equal
um ethical interaction and we'll get in
the weeds in a few minutes about
what are the behaviors and practices and
the things that need to be happening on
the ground day to day to create that
kind of environment
so before i do that i want to just say a
little bit more about ethical ai
development
so that kind of um positive team climate
with those kinds of interactions are the
basis of ethical innervation and
if you strip it all the way back it's
ultimately
because we need to hear all the voices
all the time
across the ai
development pipeline from discovery to
deployment we need to hear from older
and younger members of our team
all levels of experience
all levels of expertise from technicians
to content experts and also ethicists
community members
everybody with different backgrounds
like experiences cultures and from
different communities so that all of the
um
considerations that need to be
looked at in designing and deploying
these tools are brought to the table and
that everybody has equal equal chance to
bring up these concerns and bring these
ideas there because we're trying to
solve really complex problems in society
with a lot of these tools and a lot of
ai development and the teams that are
doing that are really complex
and my next slide i just want to say a
little bit more
about
what is ethical data science and ai
innovation and biomedicine
so what does that mean to design deploy
and
design develop and deploy ai
applications and tools that are ethical
lots of people are trying to answer this
question right now
and um
i kind of
tried to summarize what i'm seeing in
the literature this isn't everything but
this is a good way to kind of start
thinking about it
it's respect and benef it's developing
ai applications and tools that respect
and benefit the communities that provide
data and attend to their preferences
safely and equitably contributing to
human well-being health access and
health outcomes and adhering along the
way to fundamental ethical principles
such as respect
fairness privacy non-discrimination
transparency and
ensuring that we do good to others that
we avoid harm
and that we provide benefit and
following any legal or regulatory
requirements along the way one of the
challenges that we have right now in the
space is that legal and regulatory
concerns are related to some ai
innovations and the use of big data and
biomedicine lag behind some of the
technical advancements that we're able
able to
um achieve at this time and so
it's going to be interesting to see the
next five to ten years how um
globally and in the us we address these
this
problem
but
these
concepts i you know they resonate i
assume they sound good respect and
benefit and safety and equity but effort
putting those ideals into practice
requires day-to-day
behavior and that sometimes difficult
think about how do we take from this
desire researchers want to do good work
that's
99.9 of the time why they're doing the
work they're doing they want to do good
work they want to do the right thing
they want to make a positive impact on
society
and these are important and good ideals
but it requires that day-to-day practice
um
and that's why
i'm saying
attending to
ethical interactions as just an absolute
fundamental component is a great first
step in the right direction i have one
more slide that takes us a little bit
more on the detour from the
central
emphasis on relationships that i want to
share with you because this is sometimes
a source of confusion
for researchers
i was going to say maybe especially
early career researchers but i would
just say researchers in general so my
colleague and i wrote this paper where
we were talking about when people talk
about ethics and research
depending on the stakeholders focus
sometimes they mean different things
um
and it can kind of cause a sense of
confusion of like what am i looking at
here in this space so we argue that
in today's
environment there are kind of five ways
that people mean it mean research ethics
so there's normative ethics so that's
like your traditional maybe philosopher
ethicists they look at the classic sense
of determining what's right and wrong in
biomedicine trying to establish dining
principles of what makes an action or
activity and the biomedical states
acceptable or unacceptable
so that's sort of that philosophical
what's right or wrong
then some
stakeholders in the research environment
especially institutional officials they
think about compliance making sure that
we follow applicable applicable research
regulations laws rules and policies such
as insuring and consent forms
ensuring consent
that's another way that research ethics
is kind of conceptualized and again it
goes back to stakeholders
um
the third is the idea that we've got to
do science that's reliable and
trustworthy and that our methods must be
found so you guys have seen as young
researchers the emphasis on rigor and
reproducibility that's just exploded in
the last five to seven maybe 10 years my
time concept is a little different now
that the
pandemics happened two years i think
probably five seven to ten years now
um another dimension that's been
emphasized we wrote this paper in 2018
and i've only seen it explode um
especially with the pandemic
the meaning that that ethical research
is research that has social values so
it's
addressing problems important to society
and engaging relevant stakeholders and
doing so in a way that's equitable and
it's addressing um
providing benefit to the communities and
the people that really need that benefit
um
and then
the fifth is
kind of the thrust of the presentation
today which is workplace relationships
so
there's a risk to science when relations
when relationships sour and we must
really genuinely care about the
perspectives of multiple stakeholders in
research particularly as we're trying to
tackle even more complex problems with
more complex methods
so i'm essentially arguing that there's
these multiple meanings of research
ethics and sometimes that can make it
confusing
for researchers like exactly what are we
talking about but all of these are
important for ai um
ethical aia development and deployment
and
the other point is that we were arguing
this paper that the way we treat each
other ethical interactions is an ethical
issue in and of itself and you're seeing
that more and more
um
even among calls for proposals among nih
wanting to know how are you going to
establish a safe and supportive work
environment how are you going to provide
for an inclusive environment where
everybody's talents are able to be
developed and able to be brought to the
table so
the point is that this is both a
component of ethical research and it
fosters all of the other pieces so
that's why i really focus on it today
but in some of my practical advice and
checklists i'm really speaking to
multiple of these different meanings of
ethical research
so going back that was my kind of detour
to what is ethical ai and one of these
different meanings of research ethics
going back to this idea we need to hear
all voices across the ai development
pipeline to achieve ethical innovation
most people agree with this
but this is a classic scenario of easier
said than done
um
the same things that make innovation
possible having younger and older
perspectives having different levels of
expertise engaging different content
experts community members episodes
technicians people with different
backgrounds the same thing that makes
innovation possible also makes it hard
um
doing this well it takes intention
it takes interpersonal skills and it
takes leadership skills
and i know that you've heard sort of
this theme at least in one or two other
of the talks that you've um
had in this series i was able to see
some good presentations and so i'm just
i guess i'm here to say i agree and to
add
um
just to kind of go a little bit further
down this path of what gets in the way
of cultivating positive interpersonal
interactions in team climate
one is
time time is finite resource and it
takes some time to attend to these
matters and prioritizing it as something
that's essential to doing good research
um
most of us are are over extended and
limited time and
we often think about building
relationships maybe that doesn't feel
like it's getting work done and we have
so many requirements and demands on us
that we kind of focus on the do do do
test tasks
and
even the you know the nature of
communication and meanings can sort of
get a little bit
um less than desirable when you're just
so strapped for time you're just trying
to get down in the nuts and bolts you
can be shorter with people for example
without even really needing to or having
any illidan
um
lack of adequate team planning
coordination and leadership again
some of that is because it takes time
and prioritization also it takes skills
and many of us are not trained in these
aspects of doing research
and
the reason that planning and
coordination and leadership are
essential to interpersonal interactions
is
it's
nearly impossible if not impossible to
have a positive team climate if people
don't have
clarity about their role and they don't
have access to the information that they
need and the resources and the tools and
the help and the sport and the team
interaction that they need to actually
be effective and they're what they're
trying to contribute to the team so
you have to get that
the team dynamic of the planning and the
coordination right
um
when you're trying to ensure that you
create positive interactions and team
climate
the third point is
that we lack
sort of just the pants to sit back and
think about communication strategies and
perspective taking um so i'm going to
talk a little bit about that in the um
in a few minutes
and just the lack of know-how that about
how to cultivate these interactions
because it hasn't been as much
emphasized in the last
you know and training scientists and now
it's just exploding in terms of what
people are talking about it's important
which is which is good to see um but on
the upside
um
scientists have curiosity and they have
an eagerness to learn and i think that
that puts us into a great position
to um start to think about how do we
make the time how do we prioritize how
do we um how are we going to be
effective with team planning and
coordination
how to be effective with leadership and
communication so that's sort of my um
pep talk
light here tries to sort of
conceptualize building from some of the
literature of like what are all the
features that go into a effective
scientific team
um
on the left
with box one that's your team structures
like who's what disciplinary knowledge
are you bringing to the table what
expertise and background are you
bringing to the table what are the roles
and what's the composition of the teams
maybe it's multi-teams
contributing to a larger collaboration
and what are the project goals and
objectives so that's your research
planning and team formation
and then i'm going to jump before what
are we trying to achieve we're trying to
have some productivity quality of work
innovation ethical research and we're
trying to
create an environment where people feel
a sense of contribution and satisfaction
and then in the middle of what i'm
sharing with you today
this idea that
we need to create space for team
planning and maintenance and we need to
think about individual behaviors and
that's individual behaviors bucket i'm
going to focus on communication
strategies and perspective taking and in
the team behaviors and norms um
bucket i'm going to share with you
practical advice around establishing
goals and expectations information
sharing and participation
productive conflicts shared
communication norms and leadership
and i have this gray sort of box
to represent positive team climate
so positive team climate is both
um
created by the behaviors and norms in
both of these two blue boxes the team
behaviors and norms and the individual
behavior of norms and also reinforced by
and then those behaviors and norms are
also reinforced by houses a positive
team climate so sort of like
a self-fulfilling feedback loop where
creating a good environment fosters
even more of the things we want and
doing the things we want creates that
kind of environment and that's why if we
start with team planning
and goal setting up front and try to be
strategic and intentional we're better
able to think about
creating the kind of environment that we
want to see
so now
i'm going to shift
so let's get practical
so as i mentioned on that last slide
with the two
boxes in the middle i'm going to talk
about team behaviors and norms and i'm
going to talk about individual behavior
so in the team behaviors and norms
section
i um
pulled together a checklist
built from my research and from some of
the research on multi-disciplinary
collaboration and team science
um
i tried to pull together a checklist
that would represent important um
features and and components of team
planning and maintenance over time
um i think it has it has 10 items
i pulled together a team checklist a
team kickoff checklist
sort of that initial meeting that you
might have or it may even take a couple
meetings um to really kick off
and then i pulled together a team ethics
checklist at the risk of making ethics
look like it's separate from one and two
rather than integrated i wanted to kind
of spell out what are the kinds of
things
we can be doing in scientific teams to
think about ethics in the day-to-day on
the ground day-to-day practice
and then for individual behaviors i have
example
um statements
of um
for communicating different types of
things that you would need to
communicate in scientific teams and
these would be relevant to individual
team members across the spectrum and
especially relevant to um team leaders
because
team leaders set the tone they lead by
example so
having these statements coming from team
leaders helps to foster that sort of
like okay that's how we do things here
um and then i'm gonna talk a little bit
about perspective taking
as an underlying important thrust and um
skill in interpersonal interaction and
communication style
okay so i'm gonna split this checklist
this team planning and maintenance
checklist into two slides ten items
total um and then on the right side
i kind of tried to illustrate the domain
that i'm speaking to with each of these
items and i created this so that it
reflects both team planning so our team
has a plan for and then our team has
which would be maintenance more of the
long-term ongoing component where you
would want to continue to
have these things in place and evaluate
them over time
so um
the first two are
related to meetings what's the plan for
um meetings what's the frequency and
what's the agreed upon modality
having meeting agendas and note-taking
to document important decisions that are
made in meetings maybe you don't
actually need like verbatim meeting
notes but documenting decisions and
issues that are coming up
um
is becoming even more and more important
as teams get bigger and collaborations
become more complex
so i really want to emphasize the value
of these two things and um in my
experience coaching researchers
the things i've seen happen when teams
don't need enough you go off and do your
tasks and it's like oh we don't have
time to meet
and there's definitely a world in which
you can meet too much
um but even if you're doing 15 30-minute
check-ins with individuals or the
collective team
meetings really provide a lot of value
um and are a good use of time if you're
able to make make them effective
then i have
what's the plan for coordination of
day-to-day activities and then any kind
of daily ad hoc as needed communication
within the team
um
what's the plan for making sure that
there's clarification for all team
members regarding what their roles and
expectations are and that we revisit
them over time
and then the last is
really valuable strongly recommend
some kind of team operating manual or
collaborative agreement
describing the plan
the expectations
essentially how the team as members will
operate
i'll say a little bit more about this
in a minute because this is something
that you could actually go over in a
kickoff
and
also the other thing i'll say i'll go
ahead now
it's important to have something like
this but it doesn't matter if no one
knows it exists or you don't discuss it
collaboratively or there's no sort of
shared buy-in that like this is a thing
we have that helps guide our operations
and we should know it exists and be
sensitive to it and even it can change
and grow over time
so now i'll move on to six through ten
and these focus on
first two focus on leadership and
management so
what's the plan for how leaders in
manual who will oversee
progress
and interact with um
each other so if you have multiple teams
or project teams or that are being
managed you got to have a consideration
of how those
different projects are going to interact
with each other
over time to both discuss project
milestones but also just how the teaming
process is working
an essential
component of leading and managing
science that is really time consuming
and it's hard
is
there's got to be some sort of structure
and plan for leaders and managers who
are verifying that the plans and the
procedures that we've agreed to
operationally are being followed
that there's feedback being provided
on the science itself
and the procedures
and that any obstacles that are that
arise
are removed
and trying to do that proactively versus
reactively is really key
being conscious about a plan number
eight for training and professional
development for all team members to
foster their effectiveness and their
rules
and then
ongoing ongoing team process quality
improvement with time explicitly set
aside for this
maybe it's every
once a month at first or once every six
weeks or once a quarter or once every
six months or once a year once you're
really going but looking at what's our
process
quality improvement and taking time to
reflect on that
even something as simple as like are we
meaning enough are we meeting too much
should we restructure our team meetings
are the wrong people at the meetings do
we need other people at the meetings um
those are important issues
that need to be reflected on over time
and then number 10
onboarding onboarding onboarding
this is something scientific teams
tend to struggle with a bit because it
is really time intensive but bringing
everybody into the fold
in terms of daily operations again how
are we going to function and one of the
tricks here is that the team can change
over time so people are offboarding and
onboarding especially when you think
about students and trainees who are
contributing to scientific projects
and that newcomer doesn't have the same
perspective as the person that's been
there and trying to get them up to speed
takes a lot of intention
especially if maybe the kickoff was
truly a kickoff for the beginning of a
four-year project or five year project
or even a two-year project now you don't
have another kickoff um how do you get
that newcomer up to speed that's where
your operating manual your collaborative
agreement that spells out rules
expectations can provide sort of this
living document that is something that
can be used for onboarding during a
kickoff and then onboarding newcomers
over time
and then
my last check
list item is just to kind of remind you
this is not necessarily 100 exhaustive
nor will it meet everybody's needs but
these are really essential features that
i would strongly encourage that you're
thinking about routine planning and then
maintenance over time
so now i'm going to move to i think it's
a nine point checklist related team um
kickoff meeting
so a team kickoff
all of this is really in that domain
it's in multiple domains like
coordination
projects team coordination communication
leadership and onboarding
so
here's my recommendations of the things
you would want to ensure that you're
covering in a kickoff
you've discussed all plans norms and
expectations on the team
planning and maintenance checklist so
like you've discussed everything that's
on the prior thing that you've already
kind of spelled out and defined about
operations and how the team's going to
function
you've shared and discussed that
operating manual or collaborative
agreement and this could be revised or
additions could be could be added with
input even that comes up in the
checklist like hey i noticed this why
don't we think about adding this idea or
how are we going to navigate different
issues that come up
heard from the project leadership and
management team about their leadership
and teamwork style and philosophy sort
of setting some of that groundwork for
that climate that you're trying to
create up front one of the things that
um
effective leaders do is they say out
loud what they value prioritize and care
about and so i just can't emphasize
enough the value of just a few sentences
a few words um it doesn't have to be a
you know an hour-long speech a few sins
and a few words about um how
you want the team um
work the team environment to look and
function and how that's really important
to you to hear from everybody and have
everybody's with the table um
really helps to foster that sense of
what are we trying to achieve here in
terms of the way we're going to work as
a team
um four
communicated about the known strengths
and limitations of the disciplines
involved and anticipated potential
sources of past conflict
so actually getting people engaged in
conversations around
how their disciplines function
technically and how their disciplines
operate and see the world
is really really valuable because you're
you only know your discipline you only
know your kind of lens your experience
and
starting to have people think about the
strengths and limitations of their own
discipline is really valuable and then
having that crosstalk about that
especially if you're engaging people
that you're not used to collaborating
with such as social scientists or
ethicists
um having everybody getting to speak up
like this is how my discipline works and
why and how and here's some limitations
really starts to get people to
understand sort of okay we're not all
coming out it's the same that's what we
want again the things that make
scientific multi-disciplinary teams
effective and able to animate are also
the things that make it make it hard at
times
point five is hearing from all team
members at all levels about their
experience or their expertise and their
interests so that other team members
know
if you bring together all the greatest
technicians and all the greatest content
experts and all the experts
that you can to achieve the research
goals but people don't know who has what
expertise or what interest it makes it
hard to tap into the right expertise at
the right time so creating that shared
mental kind of understanding of who
knows what and also just who's
interested in what because sometimes
project needs come up where
somebody's willing to tackle a new
aspect of a project or explore a new
issue and that's just something that
they're just kind of like a pet think
and they get that opportunity and that
helps develop people within the team and
engage them and make them feel like
they're contributing
okay and then my
last six through nine
whenever we write research proposals if
you're doing research that's funded we
establish goals and objectives we
establish milestones and timelines
but i can't tell you i mean most of you
have done projects so you've probably
seen this like you have it written
and you wrote it and it looked beautiful
and it scored well and it's awarded but
you still have to revisit those because
everyone didn't necessarily see that
last uh and wasn't necessarily involved
with writing all the elements of the
proposal and also things shift and
change over time it's been months since
you wrote that so revisiting it is
really valuable
um versus just like
saying go read the proposal everything
you need to know is there it's a great
idea to have everyone read the proposal
but also establishing and
re-establishing goals objectives
milestones timelines is really valuable
um
discussing as a group
ethics as a priority and the ethical
concerns and issues that we think might
be relevant to our projects
so
um
again i said before researchers want to
do the right thing they care about
research they about research ethics and
they care about
their work having an impact on society
and and being of value
um and i mentioned that those ideals are
fantastic the trick starts to become how
do we make that happen in the day-to-day
on the ground with our own projects so
prioritizing it and discussing it
explicitly is
one important step in the right
direction there
i said before talk about your
disciplines and possible areas of test
conflict aid is a very related concept
discussing potential challenges
um in the teams like different languages
and jargon and the disciplines that are
represented across the team
and then nine
this goes back to establishing
expectations for the team environment
from the beginning
talking about
how um
there's negative forms of conflict and
positive forms of past conflict and we
want to minimize the negative and
encourage debate and productive conflict
and how that's actually critical to
innovating um and achieving the project
goals so again
saying out loud some of these things
that um those of us who have worked in
the research environment know to be true
because we've seen them over time but
making it explicit for everyone and um
is really helpful when we're taking off
the project
and then my next and final checklist for
you guys
is an ethics checklist i went ahead and
crammed this all into one slide so
forgive me for the wordiness
i tried to bold although i'm not sure it
shows up that well on the slide the key
pieces of each of these elements
this is not exhaustive but these are
some of the key features
and again these points cross those five
dimensions
of compliant
broader
rigor and um
research normative ethics issues so the
first is
maybe there's an agenda item at team
meetings or at least some routine
meeting focused on broader consequences
of data and analysis practices
we discuss at team meetings
emerging or potential ethical concerns
team leaders talk about ethics and the
value of it and research
rigor as an essential priority
when doing the work
this fourth one
is one if you do have compliance
elements to your research project
it's important that even though we know
that sometimes compliance elements to a
project especially if you're using
human data that's not identified and you
have to get
an irb involved can be burdened
it's just a reality
but the way we talk about compliance
within our project teams really does
start to shape an attitude around
what it means to be a responsible
scientist and we found in some of our
work that
kind of keeping a positive attitude even
even if acknowledging well this is
frustrating or a burden um but seeing it
as an essential part of doing um good
responsible research is of important
it relates pretty well to
um
this idea of the two two down about
regarding compliance offices resources
and staff as supporters of research not
at adversaries so i do some other work
talking to the people on that side of
the scientific enterprise the people who
are interested in compliance and
regulations and one of their biggest
notes is sometimes researchers see us as
like adversaries when really we're
trying to support research we're trying
to ensure that researchers are able to
do research in a way that complies with
rules and regulations and keeps them out
of trouble keeps their team out of
trouble and keeps their institution out
of trouble and allows us to be
um
[Music]
accountable to
to these roles into the public and
create trust
i have listed here engaging ethicists
throughout the entire research life
cycle
especially especially from the beginning
but really throughout and if you're
identifying potential consequences that
are of concern
in
in a project bringing them in at some
point um
is really something to consider and is
important and contribute to your guys's
ability to sort through the issue
engaging community stakeholders whenever
feasible but getting perspectives
outside of the research team
if you've never worked with community
members
or other stakeholders outside of the
team on a project it's just so
illuminating to hear from them and their
um their vantage point because they can
bring up broader consequences or
questions
that can really affect our thinking
about the problem or our thinking about
the data and
bringing those voices up in when
possible along this life cycle
is really valuable
the last few points i have one about
authorship because we're all
tend to be pretty conscious of
authorship credit and so discussions
that are explicit about that
isn't
are valuable
and then the last two
documentation documentation
documentation written procedures written
procedures written procedures
say that three times
um
again this goes back to prior
organization and time we're rushing
through but project teams need standards
and written procedures that are also
monitored and followed up on for data
everything data data documentation data
security data sharing data backup
everything along a data's life cycle
along the pipeline we've got to have
expected standards and procedures for
that and be checking in that our team is
following those
and again if the project has any
research compliance requirements having
standards and written procedures for
following those requirements and
documentation that those requirements
have been followed is really valuable
especially in large complex
multidisciplinary teams
so those are all of my
practical tips related to team
behaviors and norms and trying to kind
of drill down like what would be the
practices and the things we would need
to be attending to
and then my next few slides
speak to the individual
so it's going to feel like a shift but
it's intentional
so now we're going to shift and on this
first slide
i have communication functions on the
left and i have example statements on
the right and these are sort of more of
your task focused
communication so i have
encouraging participation managing
conflict handling mistakes and
clarifying expectations and i have an
asterisk there especially good for
managing up so the conflict is the
concept of managing up you may have
heard of it from some people call it
like managing your boss
it could be managing your mentor
um is the idea that sometimes people who
are um
is the idea that you're using skills
like some of these communication skills
to bring out the best in yourself as a
member of the team
so
i say that clarifying expectations is
really useful for managing up because
sometimes when you're
depending on where you are on the team
there there just simply may be
unclarified expectation you may not you
may be concerned that you're not on the
same page so
having these strategies of
asking directly is really valuable to
trying to get that kind of clarification
so i'm now just going to give an example
or two for each of these um
hopefully these slides will be a
resource reference for you in future
which i'm happy to share i'm happy to
share them
so encouraging participation
imagine sitting around a meeting table
asking
what are we missing what other
suggestions do you have
um
saying this is new for us we need
everybody's input
managing conflict
um i think these are all nice statements
it seems like we're seeing this
differently will you tell me more about
your perspective on this
um if it's a little contentious you
could say i know we're not seeing eye to
eye on this issue now but i'm optimistic
we can work it out
if it's even more contentious and
uncomfortable starting the conversation
when you're in a more tense kind of
conflict
is
often the hardest part so you could
start with
it is difficult for me to raise this
concern and ish and wow whatever issue
may not be intentional this is upsetting
for me let's talk about it more
um and then the last one is just
i appreciate the opportunity to explore
this issue with you
handling mistakes some of the work i've
done has shown that the way that project
teams and project team leaders handle
mistakes
is really
a key feature in creating a
psychologically work safe work
environment because remember part of
that is knowing like if you do mess up
that you're going to be able to raise
that issue and talk about it and i've
seen um
lack of
front end
well uh
lack of handling mistakes well early on
ballooning into problems and in my
experience coaching researchers
so
when a mistake is comes to
the forefront saying something like what
can we do to resolve this problem what
can we learn from this or if it's let
you know if you're like really down
about it which
i think this is almost exactly something
i said within the first month of one of
the projects i
i launched recently because one of the
newcomers to the team into the center
made a mistake his face was just
so upset and i was like this is not how
we hoped this launches this recruitment
feature our recruitment process of the
project would go but we'll figure it out
and his whole face changed like okay
she's not angry but i was not happy
either so that's why i was like
not how we helped it go but we'll figure
it out
um then things for clarifying
expectations
be saying like let me let me repeat what
i think we're planning to do then we can
discuss or fill in any
and there's other examples there
the second list of communication
functions these are more relationship
focused
so
definitely the way you handle those task
focused communications on the previous
slide
influence and inform relationship
building but these are more expressly
about relationships expressing
appreciation i really appreciate your
work on this providing support and
encouragement what what helps you need
or you can do this i'm confident in you
and then just connecting with people
just getting to know people for who they
are what are the biggest and who are the
biggest influences on your career so far
and why
what do you like most about this project
or this work
and then
perspective taking is sort of like the
cognitive twin of emotional empathy
where empathy is like a more affective
you're feeling other people's feelings
and perspective taking is sort of
imagining
what
how another person sees a situation and
these are really
underlie a lot of communication conflict
resolution and interpersonal interaction
so i wanted to take a second to say
um a few words about
some of the questions you can be asking
yourself so one is one is to just test
your assumptions what assumptions am i
making here what evidence do i have for
my thoughts to believe
um
next is just imagining the other
person's view so how might this person
think or feel about this situation
problem or issue and then
the last one is to really self-reflect
on things like what am i really
concerned about here what do i really
care about
am i admitting the limits of my
knowledge here how could i be deceiving
myself
these are sort of those internal sort of
the thoughts and questions that you have
in your own mind as you're going through
these interpersonal dynamics
and now i'm reaching towards the um last
few slides
and here's a other tips i always give
early career researchers
so
you've been told to develop your network
i'm just here to say yes
do not underestimate the value and
importance of developing your network
early and often
cultivate multiple mentors
don't expect one or two people to be a
super mentor that can provide you with
all the mentoring you need and also
go to peers peers provide great
mentoring
learn to seek help and outside
perspective or expertise
know the resource the resources
available to your institutions you can
tap into them
this is so hard learn to say no
ask people you really respect for more
senior to you how they've done it um you
can get some good insights don't forget
to celebrate successes and small wins
along the way because our research is
is a lot of work it's hard there's a lot
of setbacks so
forget not forgetting to stop and
celebrate even if it's in a small way
and that also builds um team
relationships to say yeah guys we nailed
it okay now i'm on the next thing
attending distress
in my coaching experience with
researchers
when stress and anxiety get out of
control it's just really difficult to
show up and be your best self and it's
very difficult to be an effective leader
and to cultivate relationships and
scientific teams when you're stretched
so thin that you're just
constantly operating on the pressure all
the time
and relatedly monitor your self-talk and
practice self-compassion so this is the
idea is listen to the things you tell
yourself so an example would be negative
self-talk would be something like
i've never done this before and i'll be
bad at it and positive would be
something like this is a wonderful
wonderful opportunity for me and i'm
going to learn from it and grow
and practice self-compassion is the idea
and i feel like it's useful to say this
after two years of a pandemic is the
idea that you treat yourself with the
unkindness with the same kindness you
would treat others so giving yourself a
break um
and saying no
you did your best you're good you're
going to get this you're going to get
through this just giving yourself
kindness
this is a list of references that kind
of i've used in this presentation and
that are useful future future reading
for you guys
um a lot of these if they if that title
resonates i encourage you to take a peek
some of them are short
call to action
invest the time to prioritize in this
human dimension of doing research
involve ethicists and social scientists
and projects and have ethics related
discussions throughout all phases
last but not least i'm going to leave
you with three quotes this first quote
was actually something that
one of my coaching clients said
when he had this i saw the lightbulb
moment like i really feel like i saw it
we were in a zoom call he was like
i just realized
the problems that happened in my
research center
had to do with
the dynamics of our team and the way
people were interacting
and he said it kind of makes me think of
that maya angelou quote people will
forget what you said people will forget
what you did but people will never
forget how you made them feel so we
spent the rest of our coaching time
together kind of trying to reverse
engineer how do you create
a psychologically safe um
positive team climate and
this is a good reminder
he cared about his people it was clear
it was just he had never attended to
this he hadn't taken the time he hadn't
had training he said i wish i'd had this
training 20 years ago so it's just
becoming really really more and more
important and then i have two quotes
from researchers who are part of a
study that i did
and i think that they're good ending
points one is rule number one is harmony
first and foremost we have to get along
we have to respect each other we have to
trust each other
and then the last one is i try hard to
be human i was human first and then i
learned to be a scientist so for so if i
forget the human part then that's the
problem and i worry about that all the
time because the pressure's on us and
it's so enormous you forget
with that
we have a few minutes for discussion
question
allison thank you so much all of your
tips come at a very important time for
our biomedical data science innovation
lab participants because here in
middle of june
we're going to be meeting here in
charlottesville and
many of them don't know each other
they're coming from different kind of
universities and different lab cultures
and different disciplines some are
biomedical some are ethicists some are
computer scientists and engineers ai
specialists why not we're going to toss
them into this big vat
of intellectual awesomeness and we're
going to stir it all up and out of that
we're really hoping that these new
multi-disciplinary teams are going to
emerge around
topics of mutual interest and they're
going to pursue these to hopefully take
them through to either a really
nice peer-reviewed publication
or hopefully even better
an nih grant around the topic that they
have chosen but because of
this
kind of i don't know a accelerated
process
some of these tips are really going to
be important that they think about as
they're forming these uh groups because
within you know zero to five days
they're gonna all of a sudden be working
with a bunch of people they've never met
before so all of these are really really
important
in the normal process when a you know i
don't know a grant is forming and
whatnot you've got a year to worry about
it before the grant's due
is that process any different than one
that's a little more compressed like you
know say five days
[Laughter]
how do would you see the the time frame
being uh an important variable
yeah that's a really interesting
question
so
you don't have to have an answer that's
okay yeah yeah and that that compressed
format
you really have to reach some sort of
mutual understanding and comfort and
sense of comfort
sharing ideas pretty quickly
yeah exactly and we you know through the
process i'm hoping that people will kind
of get there but there's still the just
the general things of of understanding
each other about how they make each
other feel um and you know one of the
things we've worked very hard on is to
try to identify folks who are really
interested in team science so we've sort
of self-selected people
from the get-go but uh yeah so building
in that self-selection will help but two
things come to mind it's just being
really intentional about how you could
get to know each other quickly and start
to feel comfort so
two ways to do that would be to write
even just a half page or one page
bulleted point nothing that's going to
take all day like
team
charter or like kind of team philosophy
together to get talking about like how
are we going to make this work and just
hear each other's ideas another idea
would be
to i wouldn't want to call it an
icebreaker per se because this just
always has this negative like oh
icebreaker but like some kind of
activity i was in a training program at
cold spring harbor labs and the first
thing we did was get in small groups so
you could have the groups get in this
group and we talked about stories that
had happened in our scientific career
that taught us things that
we'll never forget around interacting in
scientific teams some of our stories
were positive and some were like horror
stories
um and man we bonded it was like group
therapy
and we just became instantly close in
that cohort of about 30 people and then
we were in smaller teams of like four or
so so just being intentional about how
to get people talking early and quickly
um just to get to know each other as
people and in their experience in a
scientific environment and then maybe
doing like a short simple activity of
like
how are we gonna make this work how are
we going to make sure we hear
everybody's voices
who's here at the table
who do we have here
what's important
yeah what's important to keep the energy
going i mean you kind of mentioned you
know a lot of meetings
documenting things
um you know what else can one do to kind
of keep the energy going after because
usually when you start something there's
a lot of energy
and it's like maintaining that is always
such a challenge any recommendations yep
so i do agree i do think having some
kind of routine meeting schedule that
we're going to have and then just say
we're going to touch base every two
weeks or every month or every week
depends on your project and what your
goals are but having that scheduled and
then you can always say no we need we
need to you can always cancel it
but
i am of the mind if it's not on your
calendar it's not on your agenda it's
not going to happen and for at least the
way we operate in our center having
those meanings create sort of momentum
and accountability so
um you know no one really loves to have
like an extra meaning but if you really
care about a project and a team making
the time for that is really useful
acknowledging that you could cancel it
if you wanted v to um and the other is
maybe in that team charter like who is
what are our roles like who is leading
this team are we leading it collectively
that shared leadership that might be
fine but sometimes that creates
challenges where you don't really know
who's
moving the baton or who's responsible
for scheduling the next meeting or who's
responsible for checking in on what so
clarifying that i think helps the
momentum going
um maybe you expressly say one of our
challenges is going to be keeping our
momentum going who's going to be the
momentum checker like who's going to be
the cheerleader who's going to be the
champion like does anyone want that role
and maybe their role is to
say a few words at each meeting or to
send out just a brief email
of some kind to just keep people
connected and i think that one positive
thing with the covid pandemic has been
we are more familiar now with keeping
connected remotely and through digital
devices and through remote meetings so
leveraging some of that connectivity
that we've learned to be able to do
without being in person
um using it wisely for our project teams
i think
can can really be a benefit
i think one of the things which is
interesting is that as
we start to change from a pandemic based
you know remote interaction model and
coming back together to meet in person
we're gonna have to relearn some of
those group dynamics that you know we
may have i don't know we're out of
practice and so it'll be interesting an
interesting experiment with our
innovation lab activities to kind of see
if people remember
how to actually talk to one another in
person
that's i think your tips are going to be
very very helpful uh as they do so i've
heard people talking about having to
keep eye contact and how that's unusual
and that could be your icebreaker your
group team building of like wow we're
together this is so exciting but it also
feels awkward like being vulnerable and
saying i feel like it's weird to keep
eye contact with you right now
and
is a way to build connection just to
start the conversation
i love it we may have to do that as a as
a as an icebreaker
we'll see allison thank you so much for
sharing your your uh perspective with us
on on how to do this i will be going
through this little experiment ourselves
here in about a month and a half and
we're really looking forward to it
actually allison thank you so much
everyone have a wonderful friday